very interesting work at the
intersection of programming languages
formal methods and machine learning
theory and has had some really
exciting uh recent results um
on developing a theory of learning
inductive invariance thank you
thanks for having me i'm really excited
to be here i'm going to talk about joint
work with mili merman melissa give
charon charm and james wilcox
about environment insurance which is a
set of techniques for improving the
safety
of transition systems one of the
fundamental problems in safety
verification
in verification so suppose for example
you have a system
over enterposition of variables
representing a number in binary
which starts from zero and in each step
incremented by some even number
so this defines the reachable states of
the system
and we want to prove that no reachable
state is a bad state
and here that would mean that it's the
state where all the bits are one
so this is the safety problem and to
prove safety we want to find an
inductive environment
which is a set of states that includes
all the initial states
and excludes all the bad states and is
closed under transitions of the system
so if you start from a state inside the
environment and make a transition you
also
end up in a state inside the environment
so for example
the property that not all bits are one
of course holds
for this system but it's not an
inductive environment because there is a
transition
from a state where not all bits are one
to the state where all bits are one
but we can strengthen this property to
say that the least significant bit is
not one
and this is an inductive environment if
you start from such a state you also end
up in such a state
because that's how even numbers work and
once you have this inductive environment
it over approximates
the set of reachable states and
separates it from the set of bad states
establishing safety so in environment
influence we want to
automatically find inductive invariants
thereby improve the safety of transition
systems
and what i want to talk about today is
our attempts at
understanding the theory and the
complexity
of the internet influence algorithms by
studying the connections and differences
with exact concept learning and
classification
so i'm going to set up query based
learning models for invariant influence
and study the
the power of different queries we're
going to see that in that inference is
harder in general than
concept learning than classification
with interesting implications
on the complexity of learning from
examples as it depends
on the form of examples but
we're going to see that despite this
hardness the best complexity balance we
have
for indirect influence algorithms
actually originate from
exact concept learning with some
additional components to to bridge these
two worlds okay so let's start by being
specific about
the setting so we're interested in
boolean transition systems boolean
programs over and propositional
variables
and the problem is given a transition
system for certain class
we want to find an inductive environment
that's from
an expressive language like a rich
syntactic form
of dnf formulas disjunction of
conjunctions not merely conjunctions
so it's a rich syntactic class but um
we restrict or assume the invariant size
is bounded by some polynomial
because those if the only environments
are exponentially long
there's no hope of learning the
environment efficiently
um so these are the kinds of
environments we want to find
and there's a decision problem this is
complete for the second level of the
polynomial hierarchy
so it's anti-complete with access to a
sat solver
there are many algorithms existing
algorithms that
try in practice to find inductive
environments
i want to focus on a very influential
approach
by macmillan a lot of interpolation
based in thailand inference so i'm going
to show you the algorithm and then we're
going to ponder
its complexity so this is this is how it
works
it we start with the candidate
environment that's just the initial
states
and we verify that no such state can
reach a bad state
in k plus one steps of the system so
that's a bounded model checking with a
bound of
k plus one now this is probably
not close down to transitions of the
system so we need to consider
all the states reachable in one step
from
our current current candidate and we
know about these states that they can't
reach a bad state
in k steps of the system now
the idea of interpolation is to find a
generalization of this fact
a larger set in which still
all states cannot reach a bad state in k
steps and include
all these states as our next candidate
environment and we do that
to achieve faster convergence
once we have this new candidate we again
do bounded model checking of k plus one
we again look at the post image
um try to generalize that by finding an
interpolant adding this to
the candidate and so on and so forth
until we convert
to an inductive environment if it so
happens that at some point
we have included a state that can reach
a bad state in
k plus one steps then this is a failure
of the algorithm and it needs to be
restarted
with a larger bound k okay so this is
the overall structure of the algorithm
now the question is how to find these
generalizations how to find these
interpolants
so here's one model based approach
that's inspired by a different algorithm
by ic3 pdr
and i'm going to demonstrate it on the
example system we had before
so the way it works it samples a state
from
the set of states which are in one step
from the current candidate
so for example it could be this state
and now we write the conjunction
that captures exactly that state so
clearly
every state that satisfies this
conjunction cannot reach a bad state
in k steps of the system and now to
generalize we try to
drop literals from the conjunctions so
we try to draw this literal
and see if the the states that satisfy
the remaining conjunction
also can't reach a bad state in k steps
of the system
and in in this case they can't so we
drop this later on
and we move on to checking the next
literal
so we try to drop this literal and
checking whether
um and check whether the states that
satisfy this remaining conjunction
cannot reach that state and uh and
indeed they can't so we drop also this
little out when we try to do the same
for the least significant bit we see
that actually
if we drop it then there is one state
that
can reach a bad state in k steps 4k
greater or equal to one
so we can't drop this little so we don't
and we do this for all literals and in
this case
we end up with the property that the
least significant bit is zero
we add all these states to the
environment in this case this actually
is already an inductive environment
otherwise we need to sample more states
and
generalize by dropping literals and so
forth so
overall the algorithm computes an event
in disjunctive normal form
well it's each disjunct is obtained from
generalizing
some counter example to induction of the
current candidate
and the generalization works by dropping
literals as long as
this bounded model checking
still holds okay so so this is the
algorithm
and i think it begs the question of why
why is this what the algorithm is doing
and why do we expect this to work or
what's the complexity
of this algorithm so what's the deal
with this
abundant model checking
and this pattern of dropping literals
why does it it makes sense so maybe
there are
other things that make sense so what i'm
going to show is that
this uh bounded model check actually
does something remarkable that cannot be
simulated by less than an exponential
number of inductiveness
checks um if you want to try to do
inference without using
such rich queries and i'm going to show
that
this pattern of dropping literals can
be understood as a manifestation of an
algorithm from
exact concept learning from
classification and actually complexity
results
for this environment inference algorithm
can be obtained by translating
complexity results
from the concept learning algorithm so
all of this builds on the connections
between invariant influence
and exact concept planning so let's talk
about exact concept
so this should be familiar
[Music]
at this point so we're trying to
identify an
unknown formula file by asking a series
of questions
for example the donor can ask is
is this formula psi 1 and the teacher
responds
either yes or no plus a counter example
the learner then may ask is it psy2 and
the teacher response
these are called equivalence queries
there are also membership queries where
for example
the learner chooses a state or
evaluation
and the teacher responds whether this is
a model
of the unknown formula it belongs to the
concept or not so these are
membership queries after a series of
such queries the algorithm needs to
identify the unknown formula file
and although i keep using the world
teacher it's not a teaching model
the world oracle is better here
because we're studying the complexity
under our worst case assumption
so the worst case of the possible
examples that the teacher
may return okay so this is the model and
it's
great many algorithms and many results
can be used these for in that insurance
so use the same approach to install
inductive enzymes so the problem is that
that we need uh to implement the
algorithm but we also
need somehow to implement the teacher
and answer these queries
but the teacher doesn't actually know
we as an algorithm we don't know the
inductive environment all we know
is the program so it doesn't seem so
it seems that we need something else for
indirect influence
or different learning models for
invariant influence
so that's what i'm going to do now so
one thing the the oracle can do
is given a candidate in diet return
whether it's indeed an inductive
environment or
or that it is not and return a counter
example
and here counter examples are counter
examples to induction
that that is the transition from a state
that satisfies
the the candidate algorithm proposed to
form a state that satisfies the
candidate to a state that doesn't
uh and so the learner
chooses a series of such
candidates and the oracle returns
counter examples to induction
and after a series of such queries the
algorithm
needs to find the an inductive
environment and
in this model the algorithm can't access
the program or the transition relation
but through such
inductiveness queries and the complexity
is the number of inductiveness queries
it needs to perform
worst case amongst all possible
counterexamples and it makes sense
because usually we don't have
um very useful notions of how the
oracle can choose counter examples and
they usually
come from a sat solver okay so this is
the model
and it's essentially the ice learning
model of garnet
now when we try to look at the algorithm
we had before and modeled it
in this model so we look at the places
that access the program these are the
places
so this is an inductiveness query
but the the model check that happens in
general
generalizations this seems to be
something else
so to capture this algorithm we need to
extend the model
and introduce a new a new learning model
for indirect influence which we call
the whole query model and in this model
the algorithm chooses
a precondition alpha and the post
condition better sends them to the
oracle
and the oracle responds whether the
precondition guarantees
the post condition after one transition
of the system so if you start from a
state that satisfies alpha and make a
transition
whether you necessarily end up in a
state that satisfies better
and after a series of such queries the
algorithm needs to identify
oh sorry find an an inductive
environment
and the complexity is the number of
queries it needs to perform
and although this seems a very simple
model
it actually can capture a very large of
interesting existing in that influence
algorithms including ic3 pdr
and when we look at the algorithm i
showed you before
and try to model it in the in this model
so this part is a whole query
where the pre-condition and the post
condition are the same
the current candidate and we can find a
counter example
using a linear number of whole crease by
essentially the self-reducibility of
satisfiability
the point is that we can implement
inductiveness queries
in the whole query model and this uh
query is a this check is a whole query
where crucially the precondition and
post condition are not the same
so we can model this algorithm in this
model at least
when the bound for model checking is one
and we can very easily extend the model
for
any polynomially large bounding bottom
model checking
but that's not the point i want to make
now
the point i want to make is that this
model the whole query model is strictly
stronger
than the inductiveness query model so
there's a class of transition systems
and invariants for which there exists an
efficient algorithm in the whole query
model
but every algorithm that only uses
inductiveness queries
requires an exponential number of such
queries
so there's a separation between these
models and the algorithm that actually
achieves the upper bound is in fact a
simple case of ic3 pdr
which proves that i scanned model pdl
and the extension by
visually at all is necessary
and this upper bound is also achieved by
the same algorithm i showed you
with the boundary of one and and the
part
in the algorithm that can't be modeled
using inductiveness queries
is exactly this about model checking
that happens
in generalization so this shows the
importance
of this check for for the power of this
algorithm
now i want to highlight the fact that
actually this exponential lower bound is
quite unusual
in exact concept planning and it
attests to the inherent ambiguity of
counter examples to induction
so let's think for a moment forget about
the invite influence and think about
classification um
sorry so thinking about classification
and through a series of equivalence
queries uh
without membership queries ah
so we try to identify the unknown
formula by
proposing candidates and getting counter
examples
and classically these counter examples
are labeled examples
they're either positive or negative or
we know if the example is positive or
negative
but in environment influence what makes
sense is
counter examples to induction which are
actually a pair of
examples one of them is negative all the
other is positive
and we don't know which is the case and
this ambiguity
has an effect on the complexity so if we
try to look at
identifying momentum dna formulas then
classically
the complexity is sub-exponential or
even polynomial if you allow
exponentially long queries
but the lower bound i show you is truly
exponential so this shows that there's a
gap between learning
from classical examples labeled examples
and counter examples to induction which
more generally shows that
the convergence rate of counter example
guided inductive synthesis
depends on the form of counter examples
okay so this was about
learning models and the power of
different queries
now i want to briefly talk about uh
complexity bounds from exact
specification algorithms and this
pattern of dropping literals
so again we're thinking about uh exact
concept learning with equivalence and
membership queries
and we really would like to use the
these algorithms and these complexity
results
but we know that we have a problem that
we don't know the teacher doesn't know
the environment
um and so that's why we set up
different models for internet influence
and the question is can we
translate from the exact learning model
to the
whole query model and the answer is no
we can show an exponential rule about
the chosen separation and shows that
it's impossible
in the whole quality model to implement
either equivalence queries
or membership queries but
there are sufficient conditions that
that allow
this transformation and allow us to
obtain an
environmental influence algorithm from
an exactly a new algorithm
and the reason this is interesting is
because if we take a classical
algorithm for learning dna formulas
we take the queries and we implement
them for environment influence
using an inductiveness check for
equivalence and bonded model checking
for membership the result is the very
same
algorithm i showed you and this is
interesting because it means that we can
translate complexity results from the
learning algorithm to
the environment influence algorithm
provided that some extra conditions hold
because this transformation doesn't work
in general
and these are conditions about
reachability in the system or really
about
the hamming geometry of the reachability
and this is what we call defense
condition and essentially it says that
we're thinking about the state space of
the systems vertices of the duty and
hypercube
and if this is the environment then this
is the boundary of the environs the set
of states
of hamming distance one from the
environment and
the defense condition requires that
these states which are outside the
environment
they all can reach a bad state in k
steps
so this is the defense condition and if
it holds
that is if there exists an invariant
that satisfies defense condition
and it has a syntactic form that matches
results in concept learning with some
restrictions so if it's a short
monitoring dna formula
it doesn't have negated variables or if
it's a an
almost a monotone short dna formula it
has at most a constant
number of terms with negated variables
then we can prove that
the environment influence algorithm i
showed you all slightly
different variants uh can efficiently
infer the environment in a polynomial
number of cycles
okay so overall i talked about the
connections and differences
between internet influence and exact
concept learning
um there are still many things about
these relations and the complexity of
inviting friends that we don't
understand and would like to understand
but we do know some things about query
based learning models for environment in
france
and the power of different queries uh we
know that environment influence is
harder in general than concept learning
with implications on to learning from
examples and learning from counter
examples versus classical examples
and that we can obtain complexity
results for environment influence
from classification algorithms thank you
thank you yotam um there
there is a clarification question on in
the chat which is
i think about your theorem the first
theorem from your purple 2020 paper
uh what is n here is it the number of
state variables or a number of states
yeah so and n is the number of state
variables
okay great um i have a question about
your uh modeling of pdr in the whole
query model so you showed us
the model for pdr1 right
um can you say a little bit about
generalizing that to
uh arbitrary pdr so
um yeah so the whole query model can
model um at least the basic
okay there are many different variants
of pdr but at least
an economical canonical pdf can be
captured
exactly in the whole way model it only
uses
checks of reachability of one step of
the system
um if you look into interpolation that
uses boundary multi
model checking with a larger amount then
we have um
an extension of the model that simply
has a an extended
whole query check whole gray so
the learner chooses a precondition a
pulse condition
and a bond that needs to be polynomial
in the in the number of
of state variables um and everything
else is the same
and the lower bound the exponential
lower bound that shows that
equivalent squares and membership
queries can't be implemented still holds
i see okay there's a question in the q a
uh from sale muhammad the question is
so roughly if we think of invariant
generation as
a csp constraint satisfaction problem
then uh then what we have
is just a classical relaxation algorithm
um so that's a deep question that i i
need to follow but
um um in both cases we're learning
uh something exact and also you know
exact concept planning and
internet influence we're finding an
environment
that actually is an inductive
environment and not an approximation
maybe we should talk about it more
afterwards
great um one i have one more question on
your
uh your latter result right so you
showed there
how you can use um
exact concept learning algorithms to be
able to do invariant inference with
these site conditions right on the case
fence and so forth
do you have results going the other
direction that is you can do
exact concept learning using the whole
query model
um that's an interesting interesting
topic that
we haven't studied yeah okay
okay um i i don't see any other
questions and so
uh thank you once again your time thank
you
um